[Music]
hector mejía greets you with the headlines
for today, wednesday, september 23rd the
authorities are investigating a shooting on the
las vegas strip this happened
after 11 at night in the
bradley area of the hotel area a person was shot
uring a fight  leaving an
injured woman the victim is already
out of danger however the
suspect is still at large
hundreds of people are already
preparing for the virtual
baker strong walk this sunday the event
must be held virtual due to the
pandemic the organizers are
working to  that this experience
is as similar as possible to a live one there is still
time to register all the funds
will be donated to various organizations
helping the victims and relatives of
the October 1 massacre
the unemployment department is
hiring more than 200 workers
they receive  a three-
week training and they begin to evaluate the cases,
the new ones will focus on the area of  e
cv benefits to payments should
start next month
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will be close to 100 degrees
today the breezes will return for Thursday and
Friday but they will not cause a drop
in temperatures
have a nice day I am  héctor mejía and
this was his brief informative edition
in spanish
[Music]